qu'est-ce que tu fais comme travail
euh je suis un influenceur tic-tac tu es un
tic-tac
tu peux le faire faire une danse je ne sais pas
tu peux faire le wow
je juste
oh mon dieu qu'est-ce que je fais
euh
quelqu'un  vient de me demander
le meilleur conseil pour les
jeunes ou quiconque honnêtement le meilleur
conseil que j'aie jamais reçu et
en fait c'est tellement
facile et je le dis à beaucoup de gens mais
c'est vraiment surprenant à quel point c'est difficile
mais
plus tôt vous comprendrez que l'
opinion des autres sur vous ne vous regarde
pas,
peu importe ce qu'ils
pensent de vous,
vous devenez
totalement libre
alors
[Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh mon dieu tu m'as pris au dépourvu
c'est mon magasin de vitamines
je me concentre uniquement sur
les choses qui vous font vous sentir mieux
rendre votre corps fort
et ici
un autre produit sain
et c'est comme ça que les rouleaux rocheux
de toute façon
je reçois mes coups de langue dans ciao
excusez-moi monsieur je suis désolé de déranger  toi j'ai
laissé mon portefeuille à la maison et j'essaie d'
obtenir ces pâtes de m  e et mon enfant ouais
avez-vous un dollar acheter quoi que ce soit oui je le fais
merci beaucoup quel est ton nom
eddie eddie je suis zach ravi de te rencontrer
ici je vais tu as un accord là tu
vas oh eddie merci bien je  Je vais en fait
rendre ça pour me donner une
seconde de casting pourquoi tu m'as dit oui parce que
tu en avais besoin
tu en avais besoin c'est incroyable eh bien la
première personne qui m'a dit oui je
les bénissais en fait aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
tu es gentil  et tu vas me donner de
l'argent de ta poche alors quoi donc
c'est mille dollars pour toi ouais d'accord je
suis très sérieux
tu es mort tu vas me donner que
c'est mille dollars le
travail du moteur est fait ça coûte  moi 800 dollars
et je vais aller le payer puis-je
te faire un câlin
absolument d'
accord